>> Pete: WE ARE BACK WITH A
STUNNING EXAMPLE OF WHAT A
DIFFERENCE A YEAR MAKES IN
COMBATING CRIME.
DURING OBAMA'S LAST YEAR IN
KILLINGS ARE DOWN BY A
REMARKABLE 34% ACCORDING TO THE
NATIONAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
HIGH-RANKING FBI OFFICIAL.
>> LOOK, SINCE THE DAYS OF HIS
CAMPAIGN, THE PRESIDENT WENT OUT
OF HIS WAY TO THANK THE MEN AND
WOMEN IN LAW ENFORCEMENT FOR
THEIR SACRIFICE AND SAY THAT
EFFECTIVELY I STAND WITH YOU.
THAT IS 180 DEGREES AWAY FROM
THE LAST FEW YEARS, REALLY GOING
BACK TO 2,009 OF THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION WHERE THE
PRESUMPTION WAS THAT THE POLICE
WERE RACIST, THE POLICE DID
SOMETHING WRONG UNTIL PROVEN
I THINK THAT TONE, MAYBE WE ARE
SENSING OR FEELING A TRUMP
EFFECT NOW.
>> Pete: THERE'S MORE GOOD
NEWS.
AT THE VIOLENT CRIME RATE IS
DOWN IN THE NATION'S 30 LARGEST
CITIES, INCLUDING THE MURDER
RATE ACCORDING TO A STUDY BY
NYU'S BRENNAN CENTER FOR
JUSTICE.
VIOLENT CRIME DOWN BY 1.1%.
EVEN BETTER NEWS, THE MURDER
RATE IN THE BIGGEST 30 CITIES
DROPPED BY 5.6%.
A LOT OF ATTENTION FOR MANY
YEARS.
A 9.8% DROP IN DETROIT.
IS THIS ENCOURAGING TREND HERE
TO STAY AND DOES PRESIDENT TRUMP
DESERVE THE CREDIT?
YEAR'S CRITICALLY ACCLAIMED
BOOK, THE WAR ON COPS, HOW THE
NEW ATTACK ON LAW ORDER MAKES
EVERYONE LESS SAFE.
ALSO JOINING US AS MICHAEL, A
THANK YOU BOTH FOR JOINING US
THIS EVENING.
HEATHER LET ME START WITH YOU.
THE PREVIOUS SOUND BITE THAT WE
PLAYED SAID THAT THE PRESUMPTION
THAT THE POLICE WERE RACIST AS
BARACK OBAMA'S PRESIDENCY,
JUXTAPOSE THAT WITH
WE COULD ALL SAY HE HAS THE
PRESUMPTION THAT THE POLICE ARE
HEROES, THAT THAT THEY DESERVE
HIS BACKING AND OUR BACKING.
IT'S EXTRAORDINARY BECAUSE WE
DID GO THROUGH EIGHT YEARS WERE
PRESIDENT OBAMA TOOK EVERY
OPPORTUNITY TO REINFORCE THE
FALSE BLACK LIVES MATTER
NARRATIVES, THAT WE ARE LIVING
THROUGH AN ACADEMIC -- THAT
POLICING.
OFFICERS WERE RELUCTANT TO GET
OUT OF THEIR CARS AND MAKE THAT
STOP AT 2:00 A.M. QUESTIONING
SOMEBODY HANGING OUT ON A KNOWN
DRUG CORNER HITCHING UP HIS
WAISTBAND AS IF HE HAS A GUN
BECAUSE THEY WERE FEARFUL THE
MEDIA, THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA
WOULD LABEL THEM AS RACIST.
TODAY WE HAVE A JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT LED BY
ATTORNEY GENERAL SESSIONS WHO IS
TRYING TO REVERSE SOME OF THE
ANTI-COP POLICIES OF THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION AND TRUMP IS NOT
SERVING AS AN ECHO CHAMBER FOR
BLACK LIVES MATTER MOVEMENT.
PROACTIVE POLICING AND WE CAN
HOPE THAT MORE BLACK LIVES WILL
BE SAVED THIS YEAR THAN WERE
LOST IN THE LAST TWO YEARS.
>> Pete: TRENDS LOOK LIKE THAT
MAY BE THE CASE.
I'VE NEVER WALKED THE BEAT AS A
YOU DON'T BELIEVE IN YOUR
MISSION OR YOU DON'T THINK YOUR
COMMANDER HAS YOUR BACK OR YOUR
MORALE, YOUR CONFIDENCE IS LOW,
PROACTIVE MEASURE.
IT WITH THIS PRESIDENT FOCUSING
ON IT, HOW MUCH MIGHT THAT
>> I THINK IT ACTUALLY IS FROM
THE GROUND LEVEL UP AND NOT THE
TOP DOWN.
I THINK CHANGES IN POLICIES AND
POLITICAL APPOINTMENTS IN THE
WHITE HOUSE WHO DOES HAVE SOME
SAY ON THIS, BUT I WOULD
DISAGREE ON MANY OTHERS.
I THINK IT'S ACTUALLY TO THE
STARTLING, VERY ENCOURAGING
DROPS IN VIOLENT CRIME.
>> Pete: OF COURSE WITH LOCAL
>> MORALE HAS A BIG PART OF IT
AND I THINK THAT PEOPLE THINK
THAT WHETHER THE ASSOCIATION IN
THE CITY OR A MAYOR, WE SEE
CONSTANT CONTROVERSY BETWEEN THE
NEW YORK CITY PDA AND MAYOR
DE BLASIO.
I THINK IT'S A CREDIT TO THE
LOCAL POLICING AND I THINK
ATTRIBUTING IT TOTALLY TO THE
TOUGH ON CRIME RHETORIC OF
POLICE --
WOULD HE HAVE BEEN INVITED TO
THE WHITE HOUSE AND LAUDED AS A
HERO?
INSTEAD HE WAS CALLED OUT
SPECIFICALLY BY PRESIDENT TRUMP.
YOU KNOW LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS AND POLICE OFFICERS
LOVE THE FACT THAT HE IS A BLUE
LIVES MATTER GUY, NOT A BLACK
GUY LET MATTER.
IT DOES TRICKLE DOWN.
IF HE'S GOING TO BE SEEN AS
I THINK THAT'S AN EXCELLENT
EXAMPLE.
I WOULD ALSO JUST POINT TO SOME
OF THE POLICIES.
AND I AGREE THAT POLICING IS
FUNDAMENTALLY A LOCAL PHENOMENON
FUNDAMENTALLY A LOCAL PHENOMENO
PHENOMENON.
NEVERTHELESS THERE'S THINGS THAT
ATTORNEY GENERAL SESSIONS HAS
DONE THAT ARE ALSO SENDING A
VERY POWERFUL MESSAGE TO COPS.
HE HAS TRIED TO FREE DEPARTMENTS
FROM THE UNNECESSARY AND COSTLY
CONSENT DECREES THAT THE OBAMA
WANT YOU TO GO AFTER VIOLENT
FELONS AND DRUG FELONS WITHOUT
USED AGAINST YOU.
AND AGAIN, THESE THINGS ARE BOTH
EFFECTIVE IN THEMSELVES, AND
THEY DO SEND A MESSAGE TO COPS.
OF COURSE POLICING AND A DROP IN
CRIME IS DUE TO THE LOCAL COPS
ON THE GROUND, BUT THE NARRATIVE
MATTERS AND AN ECHO CHAMBER IN
THE WHITE HOUSE FOR A FALSE
YEARS TO THE LAW ABIDING
RESIDENTS OF INNER-CITY
NEIGHBORHOODS.
>> Pete: I STAND CORRECTED,
COLIN KAEPERNICK FIRST NAILED
ONE BARACK OBAMA WAS PRESENT BUT
THE EFFECT WAS WHEN RESIDENT
TRUMP TOOK OVER OFFICE.
>> HISTORICALLY ROOTED TENSIONS
BETWEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT,
PROFESSIONAL POLICING AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR THROUGHOUT
THE COUNTRY.
THAT BEING SAID, I THINK SOME
CREDIT IS ALSO DUE TO THE
ACTIVIST COMMUNITIES WHO REALIZE
VIOLENCE FROM WHICH LAW
ENFORCEMENT PROFESSIONALS WERE
LOSING THEIR LIVES.
IT HAPPENED.
>> Pete: DOES THAT HAPPEN
WITHOUT BEING CALLED OUT?
DOES NOT HAPPEN NATURALLY?
>> THAT IS WHERE I WOULD SAY
CANDIDATE TRUMP WAS PERHAPS
UNIQUELY POSITIONED TO DELIVER A
MESSAGE THAT OTHER CANDIDATES
FELT CONSTRAINED AND UNABLE TO
ON THE OTHERS I THINK AS A
CONSEQUENCE OF LOCAL POLICING.